So nickel is a metal which can produce allergies
in some
people, people get allergic to nickel. And
it’s a metal which is
found in Canada and Sir Ludwig Mond founder
of the
company that later becomes ICI discovered
a process for
extracting nickel from the ore using carbon
monoxide and
started a huge factory on the south coast
of Wales. And the
so-called nickel carbonyl was really quite
an important
industrial compound even though it was fantastically
toxic.
And it’s unusual as a metal compound because
it boils at
room temperature and usually one thinks of
metal
compounds as salts. Nickel is now used quite
a lot in the
plating industry for plating materials, iron
and steel in
particular, and then often you would put chromium
or
something on top. Used to be used for plating
the inside of
tins for peas and things like that. And sometimes
the sulphur
from inside the peas would be released by
bacteria and would
react to find strange black spots across the
insides of the tin.